pas on va faire un petit peu
l'échauffement avant avec 25 kg après on
va commencer par l'arracher comme le
premier mouvement en épeler en arraché
et après il y a on va entamer tout de
suite les policiers
et à la plaine Saint-Paul
la plaine Saint-Paul ça veut dire que on
est on a un complexe sportif là vient de
nous livrer justement bah tout le monde
ici toutes les filles surtout on est en
pleine préparation pour les Jeux des
îles
maintenant
ouais mais c'est dans un an mais on va
s'accrocher bah ici c'est surtout des
gros entraînements toutes les filles on
est à fond dedans et surtout qu'on a un
bon un bon coach et moi-même je suis
nouvelle dans ce club et je suis très
heureuse d'être dans ce club en ce
moment parce qu'il y a l'esprit d'équipe
la chaleur comme on dit oui
je recherche ça souvent j'aime ça et
surtout là le trophilie c'est antistress
anti-tout quoi sur la même un petit
souci ben faut mieux faire le drophilie
parce qu'il y a le trophée tout s'en va
et tout s'envole
j'essaye de gérer et puis voilà mais il
y a les mamie elle est assis qui sont
derrière pour me soutenir donc c'est
pour ça que j'arrive à faire des
entraînements mais sinon c'était pas
possible parce qu'en tant que moi de
trois enfants ça se c'est assez
compliqué le Conseil général nous aide
pour les billets d'avion et les
déplacements
et puis voilà quoi dans ma tête ça se
construit je rêve souvent de l'or parce
que j'ai une grande revanche à prendre
quand une chez l'Oise alors je vais je
fais tout pour y arriver quoi j'ai pas
de se voir mon école à la Réunion non je
vais m'approcher pour avoir alors